on october 24th 1929 the american stock
market crashed
new york stock exchange is in a panic
frantic investors have scrambled to
unload their stocks at any price
fortunes disappeared overnight
and the value of american companies
tanked
but the people in charge of those
companies had an idea
they started buying shares of their own
company stock
from investors which meant that there
were fewer stocks out there
for other people to buy and when there's
less of something
the price goes up normally to raise
their stock prices
these companies would have had to do
something to get investors excited
invent a new product or a different way
of doing things
but with this corporations had
discovered a kind of
magic trick they could jack up their
stock price without really
doing anything this is a stock buyback
an attempt by the owners of america's
biggest corporations
to hang on to their wealth while the
rest of the country suffered the worst
depression ever
this practice helped fundamentally
reshape the american economy
and it set the stage for a century-long
fight we're still having
it was a choice and it was about greed
someone has forgotten about the human
element
a fight about where american wealth
comes from
and who should get to keep it you could
have saved these
jobs but you chose not to
in 1932 the new york times reported on
the many abuses that were alleged among
companies
doing this new stock buyback thing
abuses like
using the corporation's funds to buy
shares from directors
officers and other persons friendly to
the management also known
as insider trading the president signed
a new law to make them stop
the securities and exchange act of 1934.
it cracked down on manipulation and
insider trading
and corporations took this to mean that
their buy-back days were over
they pretty much stopped doing them
[Music]
and without buybacks for an option
corporations basically had three choices
for what to do with their profits
option one reinvest them back in the
company
build new factories create new products
option two
raise wages for employees option three
issue a dividend and hand the profits
over to investors
most american companies did a mix of all
three with the bulk of profits going
towards reinvestment and wages
over time technology improved and
workers made more stuff
the productivity of american workers
nearly doubled in the 30 years after
world war ii
and so did hourly wages this helped
build the american middle class
but things didn't stay that way
productivity kept rising but wages
flatlined
a new political and economic philosophy
had taken hold
government is not the solution to our
problem
government is the problem when ronald
reagan was elected
the securities and exchange act had
successfully been scaring companies away
from doing buybacks
for 50 years but that changed after
reagan appointed a former investment
banker named
john shad to the top enforcement job
he wanted companies to put less of their
profits into reinvestment in wages
he thought more should go to investors
so in 1982
he changed the rules for the first time
since the 1930s
companies could buy back shares of their
own stock from investors
and they didn't have to worry about the
government coming after them
buybacks were back it was a really good
time to be an investor
investors wanted to keep that money
flowing so they changed the way that
ceos got paid
instead of just earning a salary ceos
could get a bonus
if the company's stock price went up the
quickest way to raise the stock price
was to do a buyback so ceos started
doing them
all the time 1982
the biggest american companies spent
less than one percent of their profits
on stock buybacks
by 2008 just before the recession that
share had jumped to 77 percent
fast forward to today and companies are
spending 65 percent of their profits
buying back shares of their own stock
the pay gap between american ceos and
their workers
has grown from 15 to 1 to
220 to 1 in less than a single lifetime
you can see what a uniquely american
phenomenon this is
when you compare the compensation for
general motors ceo
with her counterparts at volkswagen in
germany
and toyota in japan and you can see
part of the reason for this gap when you
look at how much of their profits these
three companies
spend on buybacks volkswagen hasn't done
any
since 2012 and toyota's biggest buyback
years
are roughly the size of gm's smallest
the more of their profits gm gave to
executives and shareholders
the less was left over for reinvestment
and for workers
in 2000 gm had the largest market share
of any automaker in the world
by 2017 it had fallen to number four
and as its market share shrank gm
shuttered plants across the u.s
and tens of thousands of workers lost
their jobs
for decades this general motors plant in
lordstown ohio was the biggest employer
in the county
it opened in the 1960s and started out
making big sedans and muscle cars
but when people's preferences changed or
one model was discontinued
gm would retool the plant to make a
different kind of car
but in 2015 gm promised investors
another massive
stock buyback to cut costs they started
eliminating shifts at the lordstown
plant
another cutback the second shift will be
dropped in two months
where am i going to go everybody's got
to find a place now
it is the end of the line for the
general motors plant in lordstown
ohio the cuts come as the automaker is
reporting a near-record
12 billion dollar profit last year
a few months after the gm plant closed
down the local supplier that built the
rear suspensions went out of business
same with the local factory that built
the seats
plans for a new hospital building in
town were put on hold
as paychecks dried up a local restaurant
closed its doors
economists call it the multiplier effect
one study predicted that every four jobs
lost at gm's lordstown plant
would trigger three more job losses
among suppliers and other local
businesses
that's why laid off auto workers aren't
the only ones in lordstown who
understand the effects of gm's choices
so do teachers there were some students
who just changed
tremendously this is all tremendous
upheaval
for them when you look around you drive
around our town there's a lot of farming
but general motors is pretty much the
town
there was a time where the budget was
made up mostly of general motors
we lose that revenue from general motors
that's going to be really tough for us
i hesitate to use the word traumatic but
it is
because when something like this sudden
happens
it rocks your world a year before gm
shut down the lordstown plant
president trump and republicans in
congress lowered the corporate tax rate
from 37 percent to 21
those who supported the cuts predicted
that corporations would reinvest those
tax savings
and that workers would benefit the most
the vast majority of businesses are
going to do just what we say
reinvest in their workers reinvest in
their factories
pay people more money when our
businesses pay less in taxes they
reinvest that money
into their companies but according to
the nonpartisan congressional research
service
that's not what happened the crs studied
the effects of the new tax law
a year and a half after it passed and
they found
very little growth in wage rates among
ordinary workers
what they did find was evidence for a
record-breaking
amount of stock buybacks with one
trillion dollars
announced by the end of 2018.
for decades stock buybacks have been
secretly reshaping the american economy
and now politicians are taking notice
republican senator marco rubio has
suggested giving extra tax breaks
to companies that reinvest their profits
instead of doing buybacks
democratic senators elizabeth warren and
bernie sanders
have called for getting rid of the
reagan-era rule that protects companies
when they do buybacks
they want to make it easier for the sec
to investigate them
in the hopes that these companies will
once again be too scared to do buybacks
just like they were in the 1930s warren
is also calling for a new rule that
would give workers mandatory seats on
corporate boards
that way they'd have a chance to vote on
those big bonuses that ceos get
when a company's stock price goes up
that's how german
companies have done things for decades
and buybacks there are way less common
but in america they have a long history
buybacks began in an
era when less than one percent of
america's population
held nearly a quarter of its wealth
today buybacks are back and the american
economy
looks a lot like it did in the 1920s
the question now is whether we want it
to stay that way
[Applause]
[Music]
you